as an antipodean how big is a billion no
I'm gonna go there man well what were
you taught what were you taught at
school okay so there's basically two
ways of interpreting what a billion is
there's the air there's the correct
English way and is the incorrect
American way I think I was taught a
billion is a thousand million right
exactly now that's what I was taught at
school as well although in Britain the
older generation would say a billion is
not a thousand million they would say it
was a million million this is the this
is there's a beautiful mathematical
logic to the old way of doing it which
you know I just don't see in the in the
new way if we ask our viewers I reckon
about half of them will answer a billion
has nine zeroes that's a thousand
million and I reckon the rest of them
will say a billion has 12 zeroes which
is a million million and it depends on
how old you are and where in the world
you live
let's be honest real mathematicians and
real scientists if they've got a large
number they're not really going to use
billions and trillions they actually use
standard form so if I want to say
something with 27 zeros you would write
you know something like this you know
you'd be five times ten to the twenty
seven but if you're reading articles in
the newspapers on you know BBC website
they're going to use words like billions
and trillions now there is a dispute
there are two systems there's the short
system and the long system so let's have
a look at the short system first so the
short system is based on powers of 1000
they start off with the number one now
is a power of 1000 it's 1000 to the
power 0 so that's one what's the next
step up where you get a thousand don't
you that is 1,000 to power one that's
three zeroes I'll put that over here
we've got three zeroes there what's the
next step up it's a million right it's
doing million 1,000 squared that's that
six zeroes we've got six zeroes
what's next up after that well in the
short system the next one is a billion
so a billion that's a thousand cubed and
that's 10 to the power 9 nine zeroes
after that you get a trillion which is
1,000 to the power 4 and that's 10 to
the power 12 that's 12 zeroes and we can
keep going after that so let's see
million billion trillion the next one is
quad quintillion a sextillion septillion
this is what America uses and it's what
Britain uses and is what the
english-speaking world now uses Britain
adopted this officially the government
officially adopted to the short system
in 1974 so there is a generation gap for
people who are used to the long system
you are aware that the you
okay he has adopted ten to the nine yeah
you know the UK's feed on the slide for
a while right so they should have stuck
to their guns because the the the tenth
of the twelve Asians makes loads more
sense the thing that annoys me with this
though you see so by means to like
bicycle but it's not a thousand to the
power two thousand to power three sorry
about isn't it or maybe maybe it's just
someone wanted to be say oh we can say a
billion right we can say someone's a
billionaire and we can say it more more
quickly but we use this different
definition of it of a billion but you
know yeah it's pretty high with a
trillion which should be a three then
it's a thousand to the power four not
very nice because if you ask me the long
system is more logical I can't
understand it I suspect somebody could
be wrong about it right except somebody
just got it wrong and it sort of caught
on so the long system is used by most of
continental Europe and the non-english
speaking world and it's based on powers
of 1 million so let's start off with in
the same place we started before with
the number one that is a million to the
power zero so same as before the next
power is going to be here a million so
that's a million let's write it down to
the power of one now the next power of a
million will be and in the long system
it is called a billion which is at 1
million squared it is a by million and
that's where the word billion comes from
so it's a million to the power two so
let's just join those up so one is one
that's fine million and million are the
same but here 12 zeroes was called in
the short system a trillion I actually
prefer billion in the long system the
next power up is now called a trillion a
try million it's a million cubed three
powers of a million so that would line
up with
what's called a quintillion I always
thought the only dispute was between a
billion but they all fall out they all
fall out of order you're absolutely
right
the the wrong system though is more
logical the naming of the numbers are
more logical billion trillion has
meaning whereas they lose their meaning
in the short system okay and you can
carry on like this a quadrillion okay a
quadrillion I mean I could go on for a
long time with this but if you want me
to it is 1 million what is it 1 million
well quad quad is for 1 million to the 4
ok let's really extended let's go right
the way down
okay what's ascend Tilian on it
according to this logic one sent iliyan
okay well sent so that's 1 million ^ 100
okay which is 10 to the six hundred so
that's incidentally is there if you do
it that way is bigger than there than a
googol we do have some gaps now and it
might be useful to have a name for these
gaps it might be useful to have a name
for a thousand million we don't seem to
have one now well we do the name for a
thousand million in the long system and
I love this word it's called a million a
million that's a thousand million it's
fallen out of favor that may that word
is still used I thinking continental
Europe but in Britain when we use the
long system it kind of fell out of favor
I think it's a great word I want to
bring back the middie hard so what we
got also got a billion we exactly we've
got a billiard right there that's called
a billiard like a posh person playing
snooker yeah
billiard in the financial world they
actually have that a term called a yard
and it actually comes from the word mill
yard and it means a thousand million and
the used words yard instead of saying
billion or thousand million because it's
unambiguous this is great why why have
we gone to this city system that makes
nose of
has no mathematical logic to it which is
just because somebody didn't really
understand numbers that it got created
and we should have gone back to the old
English way and I think to celebrate the
Queen's successively this is what we
should do we should all go back to the
old English way of writing numbers I
prefer the long system but I won't be
using it I won't to be using the long
system I'll be using the short system
it's the standard in the
english-speaking world Asia don't really
use these systems they have their own
systems countries like Canada bilingual
countries even more confusing we'll use
both one for each language so they'll be
using short system in one language and
the long system in the other but it's
you're shaking your head like that's not
true well I believe so you're amazed
Anya how imagine imagine but the Greeks
have an interesting system because what
they doing they need at the rather money
they oh don't get me started right they
don't use the word million here's an
interesting story is what million means
large thousand mil means thousand
million means a large thousand now what
the Greeks use is a word called Apple it
here myriad now myriad in English means
many uncountably many lots it actually
originally means ten thousand myriad
means ten thousand so what instead of a
million they don't say million they call
that one hundred myriad and the Greeks
used the long system but instead of
million they have this word 100 middie
ad so they'll now have not a by million
not a billion but I by hundred myriad
I just annoys me I just I just think
it's Irish rubbish the way everyone
started to do it it makes no sense at
least I can't see the sense in it and
the other one is just so Alec